bougez pas
voilà on mais qu'est ce que tu colles
mais voilà au lieu de donner l'image
tu mets la régie rouge mais aussi de
faire des ennuis enchaîné sa venue bon
là en geignant 62 à longjumeau vous avez
37 ans vous avez passé votre enfance à
wissous ouais votre père il ya des
marseillais qui bavardent là bas ça
m'étonne pas ce j'en suis sûr dès qu'il
a tué trois marseillais ensemble c'était
un copain victimes et 3 mars effet garde
des finances j'aurais il se marre de moi
j'adore ces gens là depuis le début il
rigole voilà ce formidable fait pas
belle la vie
ouais voilà nous ça me manque ça alors
votre père marc lavoine oui votre père
était fan de jazz il voulait être
saxophoniste mais malheureusement il
s'est retrouvé au tri postal à vaugirard
parce qu'ils étaient trop gonflé liste
voilà il était très à gauche
très à gauche très à gauche communistes
syndicalistes y vend des lumas dimanche
oui quoi les afficher tous me coller les
affiches et non politiquement et lui ça
va un peu guerrier un moment que marc
lavoine amont il ay l'adidas qu'il avait
un peu marre parce que tu es militant et
tout ça et il a dit mon grand truc pour
échapper aux propos politisé
syndicalistes de mon père qui m'ont vite
écoeuré on voit la ct partir non écoeuré
non c'est pas dur il partait tous les
week-ends en mobylette avec des copains
ils plantaient des tentes au premier
degré et il tourne et des spectacles en
plein air avec des super vite voilà donc
c'est vrai que quand même c'est mauvais
ça intéressant c'est à dire que vous
qu'elle est élevée donc pas faire de
tout ultra gauche a valu ultra gauche
mais très à gauche qu'à un moment le
discours vous ah non c'est pas lui c'est
pas son discours lui c'est simplement
que moi j'aime pas trop les chapelles
j'ai été élevé de mon père était là
témoin je suis croyant je trouve que
chacun doit trouver sa sa nature c'est
sa vraie raison de vivre très rare a
quand même un nom je crois que non non
parce que dans tous les milieux
je crois que les gens vont enfin ceux
qui aiment leurs enfants et ceux qui les
leur laisse le choix des choses est ce
aussi un palmarès très bien dans votre
histoire c'est que finalement on fait
toujours pas souvent enfin on accomplit
un petit peu le destin que non
on aurait voulu avoir on fait souvent ce
que alors vous votre père donc des fans
de jazz saxophoniste il se retrouve au
tri postal à vogica évidemment c'était
pas le rêve de sa vie votre mère qui
veut être pianiste surtout dactylo et
vous finalement vous avez réussi un peu
pour d'une certaine façon oui mais quand
même et toujours une culpabilité là
dessus un peu comme le communisme est un
échec il ya une sorte de d'un coup
d'avoir du succès quand on vient d'un
milieu communiste 10 à son garde un
petit truc de culpabilité envers les
autres n'a pas j'ai pas tellement envie
de
j'aime pas trop le brio tout ce qui se
voit tout ce qui se montre tout ce qui
est parce que je trouve que c'est une
agression un beau discours de tolérance
je passe sur apple en quinze jours on
partait pour de bon vous allez allions
faire du hard rock tout ça vous allez
tout le monde connaît l'histoire à vous
est coursier et ensuite à l'olympia il
est placer you voir et évidemment
c'était le supplice de tantale pour lui
parce que je voulais être star puis tout
le temps il a mené les gens dans les
stars j'ai vu la lumière voilà et donc
un jour
patricia coquatrix donc vous présente
florence aboulker qui vous présente son
fils fabrice aboulker et vous commencez
à faire toutes ses chansons alors je
vais les faire écouter parce que moi je
trouve formidable tout à l'heure ils
sont pas tout âge dit simplement c'est
un choix personnel
mieux vaut les bras mais elle a le
regard première et gestes
il a remis valentino
elle est nerveux on se met ça mais quand
j'écris ce texte là j'avais 17 ans et
c'est pas la peine qu'il en change pas
ça c'est que le comte s'est dirigé
directement fille qui l'a jamais fait
les toilettes ça quand on a 17 ans écrit
un truc comme ça quand on apprend que
cette série géniale type de mondino avec
catherine ringer surtout catherine qui
divise
aujourd'hui
ça fait très vieux
alors justement attendait mais quand il
était petit il était pas quand vous
étiez petits grands noms mais d'accord
valium appelé musée vous fait comment on
vous dit dean et moi titi et voilà vous
intègre un double c'est vrai ma plaidera
double parce qu'il était gros peut-être
voilà j'ai le plus gros jamais ma rivale
croissant de voir maintenant ce que je
fais je travaille là dessus alors les
prénoms enfin les surnoms changer
jusqu'au dernier comme idc ravalec qui
me l'a donnée sur le tournage du
cantique de la racaille un cahier meublé
marcouiller marcoux y avait de dire que
le film s'y prêtait vous étiez le mari
de claire nebout dans le même mais
c'étaient des échangistes qui allait au
cap d'agde il faut voir avoir vu ce film
à coups de départ donc si c'est toute
l'équipe reste ma couille non bien mon
cher surnom vous aviez là c'est marco
les grandes feuilles
oui ben cette voie mais elles n'ont pas
poussé les feuilles il a commencé par
grandir parler sérieusement à faire elle
vous trouvez bon sérieusement je ne me
pose pas la question et puis je
m'enfonce ce nom on retrouve tous
vachement beau mais cheville et en régie
on me dit aussi tout le monde vous
trouve très beau et il ya du beau linge
en régie à là il ya du france 2 et tu
vois il ya de l'allier de la et dieu lui
là où il a explosé me plaît aux femmes
alors mais je n'aime pas tellement je
préfère doudou et didier didier houi dit
mon physique je trouve plutôt dur
vous avez déclaré à mon physique je
trouve plutôt dur genre nazis couper au
couteau ce que comme je suis très
impressionné quand je vais à la
télévision de ça pour moi j'ai vraiment
pensé une institution ce que je l'inclus
beaucoup télévision donc il ya des des
endroits où j'ai tendance à me faire
mais sache plus beaux d'une certaine
manière si on parle d'eux
quand je suis décontracté quand je suis
en confiance pour ça que je reste
vous êtes bien là je suis très à ce que
je fais mais s'améliore la démarche sur
un plateau aussi n'est pas bien arriver
il est terrible
quoique la beauté ces données se donner
pleinement aux choses et puis de faire
corps avec la nature à se faire attendre
elle est où ma chanson moi on va se
faire une petite image rose areva
donc chez vous je vais vous la main
caresser vous caressez vous tenez vous
la main c'est la beauce-etchemin
quelqu'un de la beauté sans quelqu'un ça
ne sert à rien alors justement en 92 ou
les là vous avez dit ouais
en parlant du couple le côté on ne fait
plus qu'un mois ça me gonfle en 93 il a
déclaré jamais je ne dirai une femme on
est ensemble pour la vie car j'en sais
rien alors est-ce que sarah poniatowski
vous a fait changer d'avis ou est ce que
quand même vous pensez toujours ça non
je pense pas ça du tout vous avez changé
d'avis je mourrai de la femme que j'aime
aussi tu veux ça s'est un temps de
problème c'est pas une chaise qui s'en
plaindra par tous les cas c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a le démon de midi moi
non pas pour le moment tout va bien mais
moi la sexualité c'est parce que je
pouvais faire
vous allez faire des vous allez faire
des malheureuses la marque alors de
l'amour et quoi que vous préférez la
sexualité l'odeur de l'amour n'intéresse
pas trop ce qu'il veut dire donc jamais
être chez quelqu'un peut re je sais pas
du tout pourquoi pas il préférait la
mention sexualité cas ça peut arriver à
moi ça peut m'arriver c'est parti ça ne
fait pas un choc vous fils de militants
communistes
d'épouser la dernière descendante des
rois de pologne est ce que c'est pas est
ce qu'au niveau du jeu pas quand vous
êtes amenés chez nous puisque les
switchs s'est bien passé j'ai viré le
écoute un sérieusement malmené monde je
me répondent non pas la première fois
mais quand ils sont allés chez les
merengues l'hôte ce genre de questions
me déroute surtout venons de vous parce
que c'est quelqu'un extrêmement brillant
mais je vous aime beaucoup et c'est vrai
que la question je sais qu'elle vient
pas de vous c'est une question qui
traîne qui vous reprenez et que vous me
posez mais vous ne pensez pas ça par
exemple on sait pas qu'un mec qui vient
de mieux comme une histoire j'ai aimé
quelqu'un c'est tout donc ça m'étonne
beaucoup encore à la voilà par exemple
n'est pas ça le marché simplement qu'on
refuse d'être chaufferie par la vie
voilà dernière question marc lavoine ce
mariage à marrakech vous l'avez trouvé
un peu médias trop médiatisé non c'est
vrai le tri du tout maîtrisée samassa
m'a pas at-il assené pas eu des avancées
comme cette question là c'est pas une
idée avoue c'est pas une idée à moi non
c'est à dire que si enfin je veux pas
non plus ne pas assumer les choses c'est
à moi de c'est moi qui les fais attaché
de presse vous aviez quitté avant le
journal sur le dotant les récits de les
gérer quoi ici tout lu ça n'en faire
c'est que ben oui mais met en revanche
en revanche j'aime beaucoup d'attachés
de presse qui travaillait pour moi à
l'époque je lui en veux pas du tout je
pense qu'il a résonné d'une manière
extrêmement sincère
c'était à moi de ne penser que
finalement c'est vrai les attacher
président plus avec la presse qu'avec
les artistes d'une certaine manière et
j'aurais dû avoir une analyse c'est pas
très grave
comme quoi parfois faut savoir dire non
il faut savoir communiquer au tournant
du match
il m'est très sympa dit ces dernières
merci
quatre ans où j'ai heureusement